foreign
hey v come on in pizza is getting cold
you made it good grab a seat
this is roxanne she's worked at clouds
longer than any of us
hello
everyone don't be soft hey
nice to meet you when i heard what you
pulled at clouds
[ __ ] i so regretted i was off that day
just eat the free pizza and then we're
out of here
are night okay largest tax base
contributing
so then what's the plan need to wait for
michael
yes i won't deny that but just what
percent of their profits
does that feeling better you look better
[Music]
you'll never get rid of the stench of
the corpse you drop a lot of them don't
you
what's your secret zero gentlemen
suddenly comes naturally to you doesn't
it yeah odd
given how much work i gotta put into it
forest didn't show up for work today or
yesterday
no [ __ ] what's this plan all about
i'd like to hear the answer to that too
i modified the behavioral chip
it can equip any doll with a motor
reflex system
in other words make the doll move and
fight like a prime tier solo
fascinating isn't it what one can learn
while tuning
fake orgasms for the moxes i'm stepping
outside
can't smoke in here you'll air it out
later
please please fine i'll sit by the
everyone will window the body will react
as if executing a well-trained series of
movements
already tested it out on top chip's
impulses supplant any natural reflexes
so it'll make users feel like they're
experiencing cyber psychosis
but it's basically the same as when we
activate ourselves for a client
but first we turn to a mysterious
connectivity solo skills don't lie
in just executing movements the
split-second processes that happen
logistics decision-making result of
years of practice value chips capable of
compensating for that
you're probably right but i don't see
another way
alternatives intensive training but we
don't have time for that
all right gotta see it to believe it
finally
someone said it tom
pull that sequence from a kung fu
training virtue
gotta admit not bad yeah for the market
square and kabuki
uh before we start talking serious biz
gonna need to see
serious action you just saw him
i saw a bar trick i want to see a fight
got an expert in causing bodily harm
among us
i want to see how tommy handles him
the
just don't mess up my digs okay i like
it here
hey thon now
you there can you hear me look at me go
you see that
gotta do some cardio you have something
to say just say it
who me this is my impressed face
okay okay probably sells it
the chip works let's get to it then
you've got an elite force of three
muscle heads and a techie
what now guards and tiger claws in and
around
will overpower take down disarm escort
them out
clouds will be ours the ncpd has urged
calm
boss says we'll give an ultimatum a cut
of the proceeds
in exchange for never showing their
faces at the club again
and having no say in how the club's
managed
that's what i thought a half-baked
insane plan
you can't see more than an inch ahead of
you taking out the security there won't
solve
anything claws will just
h8 mega tower topmost floor it's a
penthouse
almost never steps outside its glass
walls
but i'll figure out a way to get us
inside
did the city's 20 largest corporations
wouldn't it be better to ambush him in
the street
like while he's chomping on a scop dog
or taking a piss in the back alley
why even try breaking into a penthouse
he's probably
crawling with guards he'd only don't go
anywhere without security
so one makes no difference two this is
only a show of force
demonstrating what we are capable of
which is a lot more than street thuggery
so how about it v tom roxy
made up your mind i need to think about
it
never wasted anyone before you know i'm
with it all the way
don't tell me you're seriously
considering this
st count me in judy without my
permission i already said i'd help
didn't i
thanks save the gratitude for later
please
i'll set up me and let you know i need a
couple days
have fun michael hold up
give us a lift only if you don't talk to
me
i feel a migraine coming on
oh [ __ ] that scared me
speaking of gratitude stuff i'm asking
you to do well
usually it comes with a price tag i know
you want to help i get that
but i'm more than happy to pay your fee
in full feels like it's only right
judy for real no
don't want to hear it not a word
ah
v everything okay
you don't look so hot
what the hell v you like sick
provides 330 of recommended remember the
heist
evelyn hired us for the relic i was
gonna clap
couldn't forget that in a million years
that biochip
well long story short it had johnny
silverhand's mind on it
an engram of it that's overriding my
mind
you being serious truly wish i wasn't
[ __ ] anything at all you can do
one can hope
it's late you're tired you can crash on
my couch if you want
sounds great thanks
don't worry about it make yourself at
home
after making waves in tokyo sydney and
paris their next stop is on
your doorstep night city
[Music]
the summit between china and india has
ended with the signing of a new trade
agreement
under the agreement the terrorist
iridium dispersion and lanthanum
rare metals necessary for the
construction of the gu2 orbital station
have been lifted the secretaries have
also agreed to the free movement of
organic persons and fire potters between
the two countries
is foreign